reason not to see number one it's uneven
the tone shifts between three different
things all the time part of it is like
this dark gritty thriller and then part
of it is these moments where people are
talking and getting information out and
there's like humor that comes out of the
situation and then the third part is
like there's just this action-movie
Huber they get throwing out the order
cut to somebody and they'll say some
witty line about the actions that just
happened like there's certainly a lot of
hit and miss humor in this film too yeah
like at times the humor was like that
seems like it's belongs in a different
movie yeah there's there's a scene it's
specifically where they get these two
goons to come and take care of Tom
Cruise and the scene itself is fun but
it doesn't it's like the two guys are
such goons they're trying to beat the
crap out of Tom Cruise which they could
have easily done yeah except they're
like knocking into each other in like
they there no yeah looks like slapstick
comedy I don't worry Stooges for a
minute it's like why these criminals are
some diabolical where did they get these
dudes like we're taking up hit ya
Christopher McCoy see it I know he's the
only credited writer but while I was
watching this movie I couldn't help but
feel like there was a punch-up right or
two because just the scene shift it's
like one scene feels like it was written
by one guy and another scene feels like
it was written by a different guy I feel
like they tried to make a dark gritty
action thriller but then somewhere along
the line so I was like but we should
make this a popcorn action movie too
yeah those ideas are constantly a war so
it makes the tone really weird some
things are not really cleared up some
things are a little bit confusing and
it's just a lot of the tunnel ships were
bothersome to me in
it was a hit I just kept finding myself
noticing it getting pulled out and then
being pulled in by something that was
really cool and then being pulled out
again by like what's this line here
before it was like it was a constant
like I'm in and I'm out you know um
that's what she said Wow we need to
bring that back doing love yes I will
admit the film had me laughing a few
times I couldn't help but feel far away
through it's like there are parts of the
crime thriller aspect you know the
details of you know who's getting framed
and what evidence goes to support which
theory like those things a lot of that's
really tight and then there's you know
this action scenes and then there's this
weird humor and stuff like that and it's
kind of it's not all over the place in
an erratic way but it it has tone
problems and I almost feel like like
it's it's trying to be a tony gilroy
movie yeah you know you don't have tony
gilroy here to make sure that everything
is is the sink in the tone is right it's
a spy movie but there is certain
elements that sort of remind me of the
bourne movies in a way yeah there are
business elements to the crime you know
and Tony Gilroy gets into that territory
a lot where you know there are
corporations and you know it's money is
changing hands and why that's what I
mean they had all these different puzzle
pieces but the puzzle just did not feel
smooth r is not to see number 21 own
characters I enjoyed watching it I feel
like it's because the actors brought
depth to the roles not because the roles
were written particularly well or with a
lot of dimension yeah the characters are
kind of just stagnant throughout yeah
nobody really changes you know everyone
does the same thing the whole time
that's I mean like you're right the
actors brought the depth to these
performances yet when you just look at
the material itself it's like there's
really not much going on with a lot of
these characters internally it's not
necessarily about character arcs so to
speak I mean according to the rules of
writing everyone should have heart you
know it's more about the mystery it's
about the mystery but at the same time
you know you do notice afterwards it's
like nobody changed much of anything
from this experience it kind of started
off one way and then it sort of ended
said roughly that's yeah it's like you
know the the Ark I guess is just that
people started with out information and
then they got some information yet
split-decision number one Rosamund Pike
she seemed to be doing this throughout
the whole movie oh it's like Edward
Cullen I would know they are going to
load 214 yeah I enjoyed rummy like we
said before it's like a lot of the
characters are kind of drawn flatly
anyway and a lot of the things she's
given to do is react to very
heartbreaking information or being you
know terrifying yes so much and I really
think that was so much on her as it was
on the script the thing is though a lot
of the characters are OneNote yes Oh
characters from I'm note yeah but her
performance itself was the only one I
felt did not elevate the screenplay at
all I didn't think she brought depth to
the performance I thought she was way to
OneNote and the but probably most
annoying thing to me was her the way she
interacted with Tom Cruise I thought her
and Tom Cruise really lacked chemistry
it was weird for me because I thought
Tom Cruise was doing his best with that
but with her I thought she was more
focused on her performance than the
actual interest in Jack Reacher and
stuff somebody came in was trying to
crowbar in a romantic story yeah don't
lower spell very forced but again that
felt like a weird script decision or
weird directorial decision where it's
like can't really close together
physically and maybe hint that you might
want to kiss but there's no reason
increase as to do that I just felt that
she didn't bring anything to this
performance that I felt gravitated
towards whatsoever you know everyone
else sort of brought something in
her she was the only one that I felt
wasn't on him anyone elses level I
didn't think she was as good as Tom
Cruise and some of the other you know
standout characters but I thought she
was she was fine you will split decision
number two lakhs thrills you thought I'd
like grilled yeah big time um that first
hour it was interesting to see how they
set up the movie because it was a unique
way to show that hey James Barr's being
set up right from the beginning it was
an interesting setup but at the same
time I felt that's where the default
came in because they spend forever in
that first hour trying to figure out
whatever mysteries they got going on
that the audience already knows the
answer to pretty much the majority of it
the audience already knew and the
mystery that they have going on I felt
the lack of regionality I also felt that
a lot of it was kind of predictable and
on top of that too I just want this
should have been more action to begin
with i granted we I know I should just
accept the material based off what it is
but I thought that his best moments came
in the action scenes okay so I felt that
it would have delivered more if there
was more action or if they just made the
the whole mystery to more thrilling and
I know a lot of people are feeling that
way but I have a feeling you enjoyed the
mystery yeah um yeah i mean i'm not
going to say that it's some
groundbreaking thing i thought that the
actual components of the mystery like
all the clues and stuff more cool and
tight for the most part i Mena I thought
it was thrilling a lot of times it's an
uneven movie but like I really does the
opening scene and for me it has its
moments of thrilling but overall I
didn't find I wouldn't say it's a
thrilling film I I think it's I think
it's more thrilling than not I'm not
gonna say like oh my god is a roller
sir ride but I thought it was thrilling
this is definitely a split decision yeah
cuz this the whole story with bar you
know for me that was like I really liked
getting the whole sequence where they he
sort of explained to bar is and for me
that sort of brought the the thrill I
guess you would say of like the oh no
like this guy is not guilty like how are
they gonna tie this around the right way
so I was with it for that stuff oh yeah
honestly to the reason why I might not
be feeling the way you feel is because i
saw the jack reacher the second trailer
get up billion times i was really
anticipating this movie but that trailer
gives away pretty much all the best
stuff about this film it really spoiled
a lot so i think that's why i probably
couldn't get as enthralled by the
mystery and all that i was thrilled by
it like when it when it had me I was
with it and it had me frequently I
didn't I can respect that even though
you're wrong no I'm except thank you for
clearing that up i'm glad that i know
now all right
you